Debbi that's a beautiful floor-length  down well thank you Bob but so can you  keep a secret  no don't tell Harry but I'm barefoot so  is Loras I couldn't find my patent  leather  the nominees for Best Music Store  substantially original are Lawrence  Rosenthal for Beckett Demetri champion  for the fall of the Roman Empire  Frank Duvall for hush hush sweet  Charlotte Richard in Sherman and Robert  B Sherman for Mary Poppins Henry Mancini  for the Pink Panther the winner is  the winners are Richard in Sherman and  Robin  yessir touched we want to thank  inspiring mr. Walt Disney mr. Bill Walsh  to Don dagradi and Irwin Cosmo  Bob Stevenson Jillian Jeff Dick Van Dyke  dick friends I there are so many people  connected with Mary Poppins I'm sure we  left quite a lot of mouths we'll stay up  all night thinking thank you thank you  you